(audience applauding)
- So, first of all,
it's amazing to meet you,
'cause I'm a big fan.
Secondly, I know you're here
to talk about something else,
but we've got to talk
about Jingle Jangle
because it's very rare,
I know it's April, I know it's
like not even Christmas time,
but it's very rare to come
out with a Christmas movie
that could be a classic.
And I think like it's a classic.
My kids loved it. We
watched it so many times.
Like, have you always been musical?
- Well, you know, yeah.
I started in music in the
first place, you know,
so it was really a great opportunity
to get a chance to do Jingle Jangle.
It was actually one of the most fun movies
I've ever done in my whole career.
So I had a blast and it an was opportunity
to get to sing again.
So that was nice.
- Oh my God, you kicked ass.
You were so good.
All of a sudden I was like,
"John legend did all the
songs, he's so talented."
It was so great.
It was, masterfully done.
I love the costumes, I love the acting.
I love the cast.
It was just so well done.
I had to start with that
'cause I'm a huge fan.